Well, everyone, thanks
for coming to my talk.
My name is June.
I'm a PhD student in
linguistics at the University
of Pennsylvania.
And today I'll be talking about
ggplot internals and my package
ggtrace.
So I suspect that most
of us here are already
pretty familiar with ggplot.
But just to get a sense of
the room, how many of us
has made like a box
plot in a ggplot before?
All right, that's like,
literally everyone.
Cool and I make them
all the time, too.
It's like one of the first plots
I make when I get results back
from an experiment.
So let's say like a behavioral
data of, like, button presses.
So each row is a response
from a participant
and there's columns for
experiment, condition
and response time.
So I can write a
short code where
I pass my data to ggplot,
map condition to x and fill,
and response times to y
and add a geom_boxplot layer,
pretty straightforward
that gives me a box plot.
So that was very
simple to do in ggplot.
And oftentimes I'll have
participants who are behaving,
let's say, more
interestingly than others,
and I care about identifying
them for a lot of reasons.
So I might also want to
annotate the cutoff value
for extreme outliers like this.
And of course I should calculate
it myself if I really care.
And if it's really important.
But I'm just doing a
quick exploratory analysis
and I already know how to
tell ggplot to calculate
this for me.
So labeling that same value
should be a trivial task,
right?
Except it turns out this is kind
of tricky because what we're
trying to do is do something
like a box plot layer,
except divert its normal course
of action under the hood.
So our new layer should
calculate the same variable
as our first layer.
But then instead of
using boxes and whiskers
to draw all of them, it
should label just one of them.
And when it comes
to these situations
where the user wants to
intervene in the process
of how a layer comes to life,
there is good news and bad news.
The good news is, thanks
to recent developments,
we can write a layer that does
all inside and all on the fly,
all inside a geom_label layer.
So that's great.
But the bad news is this
is incomprehensible.
Like this is not your
typical ggplot code.
So we have strange
functions called
inside the aes like
stage and after_stat
and we're using the stat and
data arguments of the geom_label
layer, which we don't often do.
So like this is still
like vanilla ggplot,
but this kind of code, it's
very difficult to reason about
because it requires
a mental model
of how ggplot internals work.
And here's what I mean by that.
So the code for our
first layer is easy
because we can get away
with thinking about a layer
as just doing one big thing.
So like, hey, geom_box plot,
here's
all the stuff you need
now go do your thing.
But we need to revise the simple
model of how layers are built
to understand code, like the
second layer, which reads more
like, hey layer, you know that data
that I gave you to draw, apply
this function to
it first and then
proceed as normal with condition
mapped to x and response times
mapped to y.
Then after the box plots
that steps in and transforms
the data, then use the
computed variable y-max
to remap to the y
aesthetic and do the same
for the label aesthetic.
And then lastly, use the
label geom to draw what you have.
That was a mouthful.
And you get the point.
What appear to be a simple
task of annotating a box plot
variable
turns out to require a
deep understanding of what
goes on where in the internals.
And it's not just
because there's
more code that is difficult.
It's conceptually difficult
because it makes references
to different steps
in the internals that we
as users don't get to see.
And I don't know
about you, but I
would love to be able
to write code like this.
So if a knowledge,
if it requires
the knowledge of the internals,
if that's what it takes,
then maybe ggplot internals
aren't just for developers
anymore.
And so that's what I
want to talk about today.
I would like to propose
a model of ggplot internals
for users, one that's
immediately practical to users
just wanting to
get better at ggplot,
but also one that
offers an accessible
starting point for
aspiring developers who
want to extend ggplot.
So here's my proposal
in a nutshell,
why don't we just pretend that
ggplot internals is one
big data wrangling function?
Because it kind of is.
And to do that, I have developed
my package ggtrace,
which I'll be showcasing today.
So here is the outline
for the rest of my talk.
So first, I'll introduce
this reframing of ggplot
internals as data
wrangling, which
will also provide context and
motivation for my package
ggtrace.
And then I'll demonstrate how we
can put this idea into practice
using a simple example using
functions from ggtrace,
starting with an
example of a bar plot
and then returning to our
box plot annotation problem
and to building up the
solution from scratch.
So our dive into
the internals begins
with this factual observation
that each layer of a ggplot
has an underlying data
frame representation.
So in other words,
layers are just data
frames until they get drawn.
So we can actually see this
using ggplot's own layer data
function.
So we pass it our plot
and the index of the layer
we want to inspect.
And it gives us the data
that's underlying the box plot
layer of our plot.
And this is the
actual data frame
that gets sent off to the quote
unquote drawing system, which
is kind of the graphical object
land with like grid functions
and table functions.
But for our purposes,
we'll just pretend
that all of the internals is
a function that just takes
the raw data that we give
it, which is the experiment
data that we provided and makes
it drawing ready like this
and does this process for
every layer in our plot
according to each layer's
own specifications.
And this doesn't
look too bad, right?
Our input was a tidy
data and the output
is just another tidy data
where each row represents
a box plot and the columns
are aesthetics that describe
each box plot, including the
value for the upper whiskers
stored in the y-max column.
And crucially, as
you might suspect,
this process of making a
layer of data drawing ready
happens in steps
not all at once.
So why do we care
about that as users?
Well, because, again,
different pieces
of the code that we write
also kicks in different steps,
step by step, to make the
layers data more and more
drawing ready.
So it's literally
like data wrangling
happening under the
hood, except you
don't get to see your
data again after it
goes off and off your hands.
You know, so kind of like this.
So I'm like simplifying
things a bit here.
But for our purposes as users,
we can think of the internals
as divided up or sliced into
these four big steps, which
I'll call the before
stat, the Before Geom,
or, Before Stat, After Stat,
Before Geom and After Scale.
And because they
happen in order,
how a piece of our
code, layer code,
changes the current state of
a data in this pipeline at one
step has consequences
for what kind of code
we can write for that
data in another step.
So, so far, so good.
Now we just need to see
what the data actually
looks like at these steps.
So we go digging
into the internals
and we find that the data passes
through these scary-looking
things called ggproto
methods and not
like the kind of dplyr of
functions we're familiar with
and the four steps that
we care about as users,
those are also the inputs and
outputs of these ggproto methods,
these three to be exact.
So in the internals,
the raw data
is input and the Before Stat
data is the state of the layer
data when it's passed
into the layer
ggproto object's compute
statistic method
that the After Stat data is
the output of that same method
and then the Before Geom data is
the input to this next method
and then the After
Scale data is the output
of this other method.
And then some more
stuff happens and then
the data becomes
drawing ready, and then
it gets sent off to be drawn.
So the fact that the
internals are written this way
is a big reason why
it's deliberately
kept hidden from us users.
ggproto is scary
and we're honestly
like better off not knowing
anything about them.
Like this first method here,
Layer$compute_statistic.
It looks like this and it's
like nothing you've seen before.
It's like a function, but it's
composed two other functions,
and it has this
argument called self,
which is like a big thing from
object-oriented programming.
That's like very intimidating
to me as an R user.
And maybe to you too, although
if you are interested in OOP,
you're in the right place
just like 40 minutes earlier.
And this method is actually
also like a nested call
to several other ggproto
methods and they're
like all written in base R and
it can get very overwhelming.
And recently they also added
in vectors integration and CLI
integration and
it's a lot like, OK,
I wanted to know what
goes on in the internals,
but not like this.
This is developer
territory, right?
All I care about is
just seeing the data.
Like give me the
data frame so that I
can anticipate what
my code will do
in the middle of the
pipeline when it kicks in.
And so that's the motivation
behind ggtrace.
So ggtrace is a package
that allows us, the users,
to drop inside
like parachute down
this internal pipeline at any
point we want and intercept
the data at that
step and interact
with it using the kind
of data wrangling tools
that we're already
familiar with.
So ggtrace
comes with a family
of workflow functions in the
form of ggtrace__(),
which all take
three arguments: the ggplot
object, the ggproto
method and when
to interact with that method.
So this talk will showcase
just two functions
from the inspect workflow,
ggtrace_inspect_args()
and ggtrace_inspect_return(),
which
lets us take a snapshot
of a layer's data
as it goes in and
out of ggproto methods.
So for example,
if we want to look
at the state of a layer of
data in the Before Stat stage,
then we can use ggtrace_inspect_args()
to intercept the data that
was passed into their
compute statistic
when it is first
called for our plot,
which gives us the box
plot layers After Stat data
and then likewise if we want to
look at the layers after that
or sorry, that was
the Before Stat data.
If we want to look at
the After Stat data,
we need to use
ggtrace_inspect_return() instead
to intercept the data
when it is returned
by that same method, which
gives us the box plot
layers After Stat data.
So now that we're
equipped with the tools
to peek inside the
internals, let's use
these inspect functions to walk
through how a layer gets built
for the bar plot, step
by step, and we'll
be using the Penguins data set.
So if you're not
familiar, this is a data
set where each row is a penguin
with columns per species
and bill length.
And so using geom_bar we
can visualize the count
of penguins in each species
by mapping the species column
to x and fill.
So simple, right?
Pretty straightforward.
We don't really think about how
layers are built in steps when
we write code like this, but
once we spell out the defaults
like stat equals count and
y equals after_stat count,
we see clear parallels to
our more complex box plot
annotation layer, which is
why I like this example.
So in the internals,
the bar labels data
starts off as the
Penguins data and ends up
in its drawing ready form.
And to see how this
all happens, we
use ggtrace to intercept
the data at the four steps
that we care about.
So let's look at
some data frames.
We start by intercepting the
data at the Before Stat stage.
So we use ggtrace_inspect_args()
again
to pull out the
data argument that
was passed into this ggproto method,
which gives us a data
frame that looks like this.
So here our initial
aesthetic mappings
are reflected in the presence
of these columns named
after the actual
aesthetics like x and fill,
just like basically
select and rename.
And we see some
other things that
happen to the data at this point
as well, like the x is numeric.
And we have these new
columns like PANEL and group.
If we pass the function to the
data argument of the layer,
this is also the
point by which that
would get applied to our data.
But the real significance
of the Before Stat data
is that it validates the
layers choice of stat.
So our Before Stat
data has a column for x
And that satisfies the
layers count stat, which
requires either an x
or y aesthetic as we
see from the documentation.
If it's specified both
x and y like this,
then the plot fails to build
and it errors specifically
at stat_count.
And so we can set error equals
true in our ggtrace function
to debug the layers data.
And here we can
see the reason why.
It's because both
the columns x and y
are present when the stat
goes in to look at the data.
And if we...
But as long as the
stat has what it needs,
then it will transform
the data, spit
it back out for us to see
in the After Stat stage.
So at this point, we see
that the data basically
underwent a group_by() and
summarize().
So we have one row for
each bar and new variables
like count and prop.
So the After Stat stage
is significant because it's
an opportunity for us to
declare more aesthetic mappings,
except we can use variables
from this After Stat dataframe.
So the fact that we have a
column called count in the
After Stat data is what allows
this default mapping of y
equals after_stat(count) and
that's essentially just calling
mutate(y = count)
on the After Stat data.
And like this isn't
just a metaphor,
like aesthetic mappings are
literally powered by tidy eval.
So the symbol count is
evaluated to the vector count.
So you can do things
like y equals count
over sum of count, which will
give you proportions and have
consequences down the
line for the plot.
And any After Stat
mappings that we
declare like this will get
applied to the data for us
to see by the time the data
reaches the Before Geom stage.
So we see now the data
has that y column present
when we intercept it here.
And just like in
the Before Stat
the Before Geom's
data validates the
layer's choice of geometry.
So here we have both x
and y columns present
and that satisfies our
layer's geom, which is geom_bar,
and it requires both
x and y aesthetics.
If we instead
overwrite this default
and not map anything to y at
all by setting it to null,
then the stat is satisfied.
But the geom down
the line is not so,
it's geom_bar that
draws the error.
And so conceptually
we can see how
After Scale mappings
are sometimes
necessary to make a
stat and a geom work.
So every layer has a stat in a
geom and they need to fit together
to make a layer come to life.
So the next time that
we intercept the data
is in the After Scale stage.
So by this point the
non-positional scales
have stepped in to transform
aesthetics like fill,
which is now a column of the
actual color values instead
of the names of the
penguin species.
We also see that the
bar geom has stepped
in to add default values
for bar-related aesthetics,
which are again just
columns like color and size.
This stage is significant
because just like the After
Stat, we can declare
more aesthetic mappings
one last time before the
data sent off to be drawn.
So for example, we have the
size column by this point
representing the thickness of
the borders around the bars.
It's actually kind of hard
to tell the default value.
It's small.
So if we wanted to make
it like five times thicker
than it was originally going to
be, then you can kind of just
do that on the fly,
grab the size column
when it exists in the After
Scale data, multiply it by 5
and map it or assign it
back to the size aesthetic.
And it's kind of like so
aesthetic mappings are
kind of like scheduling a mutate()
call on your data for later.
And this can happen on
the fly without us needing
to figure out the default value
first and then for the data
viz folks in the room.
This is also what
allows you to do
stuff make the outline
of the bars a little
bit darker than the
fill at the bars,
and then that can make
your plots look prettier.
I'll just leave
this here for you
if you want to look at it later.
So that concludes our
bar plot walkthrough.
So to recap, a layer
of data becomes
drawing ready in
steps in the internals
and using the inspect
function from ggtrace,
we were able to see
what the data looks
like at a certain
steps and crucially
how the state of the layers data
can inform what kind of layer
code that we can write.
And so with that we circle
back to our box plot annotation
layer.
Again, we have this box
plot of response times
by condition that we
made at the beginning,
and we would like to
add a layer labeling
the value of the upper whisker
in the second box plot.
And so applying what
we just learned,
we can write this layer in
steps, just like how the layer
itself is built up in steps.
So this is kind of a
hard code, so we'll
get stuck at some
point, but then I'll
show you how we can use ggtrace
to debug our way out of it.
So first thing we start is
a high-level description
of what we want.
So every layer has
a stat and a geom.
So maybe let's start there.
We want to use a label to draw
a box plot variable. In code,
that means geom_label with
stat equals boxplot
or stat_boxplot
with geom equals label.
Again, every layer needs
both and it's actually
your choice of syntax.
They're the same thing.
And next we can specify the data
that we want the layer to plot.
So we only care about
the second box plot.
We say filter for condition
is B and let that apply.
Then we build up the
aesthetic mappings,
starting with the ones
that the stat needs first
because the stat always
receives the data first,
so we specify the x and y
And then additional ones
that the geom might
need later like label,
which we want to be
the same as the y-max
value that the stat computes.
And so that gives us
this big chunk of code,
and we're almost there
except for this error
that says geom_label is
missing a y-aesthetic.
And, like what, we do
have a y-aesthetic here.
So like, maybe we're
not sure what's wrong,
but we know how to debug this.
The geom is complaining
about a missing aesthetic,
and so something must be wrong
with the data that it receives.
So then we inspect the Before
Geom snapshot of the layers data,
and we do see that the y-
column has been dropped.
So it turns out that
the box plots stat
consumes the y-column
and then returns
a summary across multiple
columns like this.
So the y-column is missing now.
So to resolve that, we can
use the stage function again.
Just this is a ggplot function,
stage function, to map y
at the start, to
satisfy the stat
and then remap to y
in the After Stat
to satisfy the geom. And then that
gets us the layer that we want
because this ensures that
both the Before Stat
data and the Before Geom
data has a y-column present.
So then that's what finally
gets the layer working.
So that concludes cracking open
ggplot internals with ggtrace.
Again, ggtrace is helpful.
It helps us learn the
internals as users
by exploiting the fact
that a lot of the internals
is just manipulating data frames
and by reframing the internals
into familiar data wrangling,
functional programming terms
that we're all familiar
with, we arrive
at a conceptual understanding
of how the internals work.
So this lets us write more
powerful ggplot code as users,
while still mostly
abstracting away
from the scary implementation
details like ggproto and base
R functions.
But if you are
interested in that,
ggtrace has other workflow
functions that you can use.
So just really quickly,
there's function
from the capture workflow
like ggtrace_capture_fn(),
which essentially records
the behavior of a ggproto method
when it executes.
And then you can kind of have
it as a standalone function.
You have functions from
the highjack workflow
which kind of lets you
pass or make ggproto methods,
return arbitrary values.
And so you can kind of
try to hack the internals
and see what you can come
up with and yeah, that's it.
ggtrace is on GitHub.
Here are some links,
other materials
and I'd love to
hear your feedback.